جسر القرم يتعرض للهجوم من جديد الروايه
الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن عمليه ليليه نفذتها
وحده من جهاز الامن وقوات البحريه الهجوم
شمل استخدام قاربين مسيرين قالت ان
الوحدات المهاجمه وجدت صعوبه في الوصول
الى الجسر لكنها تمكنت من تنفيذ المهمه
الموكله اليها اداره امن الدوله اكدت
بدورها ان الهجوم لم يقتصر على استخدام
مركبات بحريه مسيره لكنها تركت الكشف عما
سمته تفاصيل تنظيم التفجير الى ما بعد
الانتصار في الحرب ضد روسيا حسب قولها
يبلغ طول الجسر 19 كلم ومكون من طابقين
متوازيين الاول للسيارات وفيه مساران
والثاني للسكك الحديديه بمسار واحد
يربط شبه جزيره القرم بالاراضي الروسيه
ويمتد الى اقليم كرسنو داار جنوب غربي
روسيا انشاته موسكو عام 2018
ويؤدي دورا استراتيجيا بالنسبه لروسيا في
نقل البضائع والسلع وحتى امدادات المياه
العذبه والطاقه الكهربائيه وبالطبع
الامدادات العسكريه
عملت روسيا على تحصينه بنشر منظومات دفاع
جوي وقطع عسكريه قرب مضيق كرش اضافه الى
كاميرات مراقبه
الخارجيه الروسيه وصفت الهجوم بالارهابي
واكدت العمل على تحديد المسؤوليه ونتيجه
للاستهداف الغت مقاطعه دانيتسك حضره تجوال
الليلي للسماح بعبور السيارات من مقاطعه
روستوف الروسيه باتجاه شبه جزيره القرم
عبر ماريو بول باتجاه مقااطعتي
وصولا الى القرد ووصل هذه التطورات صدرت
دعوات لضم مزيد من المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
بل اكثر من ذلك فالدعوات وصلت الى حد منع
اوكرانيا من اي منفذ على البحر الاسود
وكان الجسر استراتيجي قد تعرض لهجوم
بشاحنه ملغمه في اكتوبر الماضي اصابته
باضرار وتله قصف جوي روسي مكثف استهدف
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كير
[موسيقى]